el gobierno ruso estaría utilizando las
redes sociales y también en grupos de
mensajería privados para así reclutar
una nueva brigada de mercenarios o
luchar contra su ejército el presidente
vladimir putin aseguró que su país
estaba dispuesto a utilizar 16.000
voluntarios de los países de medio
oriente en la invasión de ucrania sobre
todo en las operaciones que lleva a cabo
en la región del tomba lo que reforzó la
teoría de que el kremlin estaría
entonces nutriendo esta llamada
operación militar especial con
mercenarios de otros países uno de los
grupos de mercenarios más conocidos es
el wagner considerada una de las
organizaciones más secretas de rusia
oficialmente no existe ya que servir
como mercenario va en contra de la ley
rusa y también internacional se cree que
hasta 10.000 operarios han firmado al
menos un contrato en wagner en los
últimos siete años y también mercenarios
del lado ucraniano que pelean contra los
rusos en esta guerra esto va de lado y
lado para ello entonces quiero saber en
ese momento a frank matías bueno él es
analista en temas militares y editores
de la red ejércitos gracias a frank por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 hablemos entonces de estos
llamados mercenarios son comunes en las
guerras cuál es su función
principalmente
para guardarse encantado en el caso de
rusia que creo que es el que nos toca
por el tema de la guerra neutral ya sí
que se ha convertido en los últimos años
una de las herramientas principales para
proyectar su poder para aumentar la
influencia a lo largo del globo sobre
todo en áfrica pero también en siria se
inició en primer lugar en ucrania la
cara durán en 2014 y 2015 allí fue donde
van der hizo digamos su estreno y
posteriormente después de eso se sería
operado en libia regulación trafican a
mozambique en diversos países y es una
herramienta muy útil para el estado ruso
para hacer lo que se llama negación
plausible es decir cometer cierto tipo
de acciones sin que repercuta al estado
ruso para poderlo negar es el caso pues
que hemos visto aquí en ucrania así que
si se ha convertido en una herramienta
bastante útil para el estado ruso para
aumentar su influencia y lo está
utilizando cada vez más digamos que el
gobierno ruso nunca ha reconocido la
existencia de estrés de este grupo
wagner y además cuántos grupos de
mercenarios se conocen alrededor del
mundo frank
respecto a empresas de mercenarios como
tales por ejemplo sí que eso está
bastante perseguido a nivel
internacional sin embargo no hay que
confundir pues lo que viene siendo los
típicos mercenarios con las compañías
privadas de seguridad es dos cosas
diferentes aunque sí que es verdad que
la línea divisoria es bastante ambigua o
difusa y en base a eso es a lo que juega
rusia para intentar ocultar puedes sus
acciones como bien dijiste está
prohibido por la constitución de rusia
posee el mercè navegador así que puede
negar cualquier acción sin embargo sí
que hemos visto que en otros países pues
reconoce la presencia de instructores
como
ocurre en la república centroafricana o
en mar y por ejemplo donde también pues
el gobierno del país pues reconocía la
presencia de instructores rusos pero no
dejan de ser pues este este magnet
también los hemos visto digamos pues que
turquía aprendido más o menos pues un
poco la elección de rusia y ha seguido
el ejemplo he utilizado
mercenarios sirios en los distintos
conflictos como en libia o en la propia
por ejemplo en azerbaiyán y armenia pasa
utilizado por los mencionados siglos en
este caso ahora frank hablemos de la
otra figura no los voluntarios que van a
pelear voluntariamente en las guerras
con qué fin lo hacen además digamos cuál
es la diferencia entre voluntarios y
mercenarios porque se habla digamos de
mercenarios por el lado de rusia pero
voluntarios por el lado de ucrania cuál
es esta diferencia
pues básicamente a nivel legal la verdad
que no hay demasiada diferencia y sobre
todo me gustaría remarcar que sería el
aspecto de qué es lo que motiva a esta
gente a la hora de pelear esto es un
problema porque si esto voluntario
recibe algún tipo de compensación pues
siempre se puede agregar o incluso
recibirla por parte del ejército ruso
del estado ruso de que son mercenarios
pero en verdad las motivaciones pues es
difícil saber las veces pues es para
pelear pues contra esta decisión ilegal
por parte del estado ruso contra contra
el pueblo ucraniano
otras veces posiblemente pues para la
aventura pero yo creo que la mayor parte
de ocasiones es esta solidaridad con el
pueblo ucraniano así que sí que es
cierto que pues estos voluntarios se
enfrentan al peligro de no ser tratados
como prisioneros de guerra y entonces
pues aquí es donde llega pueden llegar
pues el tema de ejecuciones no puedo
decir tratarlos de cualquier manera
hacia el cabo no forman parte de un
ejército regular ejército para mí o no
entonces frank qué pasa con estas
personas cuando se acaba la guerra
simplemente se van a sus territorios y
ya o realmente digamos que después
pueden pedirle algo de retribución al
país al gobierno del país por el que
pelearon o se hace algún tipo de
documentos a qué pasa realmente con
estas personas llamadas voluntarios que
van a pelear
yo creo que el mayor programa para estos
voluntarios o sobre todo para los países
de acogida
con los que provienen ellos es a la hora
de reintegrar los asia a cabo estamos
hablando que se va a enfrentar a una
guerra yo creo pues en la actividad
humana más más cruel en la cual es pues
se pueden radicalizarse pueden poder ver
con cómo puede venir con problemas
mentales y entonces a la hora de
reintegrar los va a ser bastante difícil
luego pues dependiendo del
contrato que hayan firmado cosas tipo de
reproducción mensual o de completación
pues ya eso ya dependerá de lo que hayan
firmado pues cada
cada voluntario como están las cosas
como de la guerra como cómo puedes
finalizar esta guerra o cómo podría ir
avanzar e ir avanzando el ejército ruso
en ucrania
es bastante difícil poder predecir lo
que es la ocurrir pero si o siendo que
en estos momentos el ejército ruso se
está quedando estancado y le está
costando bastante más avanzar que los
primeros días sobre todo los dos
primeros días y el hecho que tenga que
recurrir cosas todos voluntarios sirios
y digamos también pedir ayuda de alguna
manera militar o contar pues repuesto en
lo que sea material militar chino ya va
reflejando que no van las cosas del todo
bien lo estamos viendo también por el
nivel de pérdidas que es bastante alto
en el ejército ruso por capacidades
debería de ser capaz de ganar la guerra
pero la estrategia simétrica que está
siguiendo después el ejército lo está
haciendo muy efectiva frank gracias por
su tiempo por estar con nosotros en este
espacio de france 24 llamado directo may
que un gran abrazo
gracias a ustedes